well time to take a look through the
Sunday papers now I'm joined by the
writer Stanley Johnson the broadcaster
Esther Rantzen and the former head of
the Metropolitan Police in Blair very
good to see you all thank you very much
indeed under will stay with you Lord
Blair and dive straight in front page of
The Observer Brussels just I mean laying
it on the line here saying you can't
really do much to deal with migration or
immigration from within the European
Union well this is turning into almost a
soap opera I think we've got Martin
Schultz now telling Britain that it
can't do anything about he's the
European parliamentary press for
President of the European Parliament
telling Britain that Britain can't do
anything about the free movement of
workers and that includes moving for
benefit you if you read The Telegraph
you've got in Duncan Smith saying we can
Sunday Times is running it on the front
page and there's something going on here
but particularly the Conservative Party
having a conversation with itself The
Telegraph's got 95 Conservative MPs
demanding a change the law so that your
British law can override European law to
destroy the European Union from the
beginning this week has seen a bill in
the House of Lords to try and get a
referendum in 2017 which is a waste of
time because no Parliament can bind its
successor so it's a complete Charles in
Qatar yoga I mean it's not just the
Conservatives isn't it because it came
from chucker amala day I mean this this
issue on the on the front of the
observer from the labor side Stanley
Johnson ira's it was looking at some of
the categories of migration within the
European Union I spent 20 years in the
EU institutions if you add the my time
in the parliament with my time in the
Commission I think it realistically
there have to be some changes on this
free movement not just because of the
migration thing but because you actually
have had over the last 10 years the
colossal increase in the population of
Britain and if we can't have a say in
what kind of population know in terms of
sheer numbers we have that is a very
near the answer is it's the UK parts
there isn't it's to leave the European
Union
you can't meddle you can't tinker with
in the morning you use hand but the free
movement of labour has only recently
been implemented throughout Europe so
you could have a few retrograde steps
and say look actually we got to start
looking at some of these you can have a
a backtrack on it but I mean you know
practically what do you think Esther I
mean so therefore I mean if you did you
would have let's say somebody turning up
at an airport or report saying right you
know I'm from Poland here's my family I
want to look at Big Ben and ride on a
big red bus and then they go and look
for a job I mean how dare how do you
categorize people coming from within the
European Union well I think we have to
accept that what the statistics tell us
which is that immigration is a good
thing economically for us and it's a
good thing in many many different ways I
remember going to a comprehensive school
in Luton south where the head teacher
told me that she depended upon migrant
children to set standards to provide
role models for the indigenous kids
because they're ambitious they want to
learn they prized education that being
said Europe has changed so much in my
lifetime I was an ardent pro-european at
the beginning wanted us in but there's
no question that there's a lot of
imbalance now between the various
nations joining together and I think the
whole I don't think it is a conservative
issue and I think it's a European issue
I think Europe needs to look at this and
work out what's sensible what works last
last thought on that mean just on the
migration issue within the borders of
the European mean I could I could
something be I couldn't disagree more
that the the expansion of Europe is a
very significant factor but what needs
to happen is we need to have the
conversation from within Europe rather
than standing there and saying if you
don't agree with our changes we're
leaving the club alleles of that is
leave the club okay another story
Stanley Johnson taxpayers foot the bill
for hs2 this is the second high-speed
rail line three hundred million pounds
already spent what on well he's been
spent on whole lot of preliminary what
I've gotta declare an interest is this I
must have carriers is this train line is
gonna go with it is 7 meters of my of my
front door and the point I'm making
seven years yes I mean we know it was
cooked up by labor cover labor
they were government before the last
election to give it a kind of no sense
of modernity well it's this government
Mr Cameron really crushing it forward a
day after they have to back off because
the real problem the moment we have Lord
of Dennis of Cameron I think you oughta
give up his tie please give up the
Camden but recyclables Camden where I
live is going to be completely wiped out
in a nutshell one of the real problems
is they have no provision for
compensation unless you're actually not
done is ludicrous so you're not going to
get anything for the fact that you could
sort of leap onto it as it passed your
back door or front doors I'll be some
late we're going to get about 20 years
of disruption mega disruption I might be
worth in the salad Olson house what do
you think many hackers we're getting
officer haircuts thank you very much
deeper I we're getting onto haircuts in
a moment or two but i just wanted to
pick out for us so Stanley some of the
things you know people surprised that
nearly a third of a billion pounds has
already been spent this is on the front
of the Telegraph isn't it I mean what
you know what you want honor that they
spent that amount of money on what
wasn't the thought of detail engineering
which has to go has to go into the into
the thing I mean you've got tunnels to
build you've got buybacks are built it's
a lot of detail work sudden I might have
gone to a phone called KPMG to produce a
study saying yes it's a jolly good idea
PR campaign anyway but actually I think
that in France they do do it different
that I would did the Newbury bypass with
swampy ah yeah again I noticed the
French of bill in the TV they compensate
people extremely well and there's no
arguments and they get on when it out
but wit of course what we do I remember
a particular bit of that road ran
through a line of houses and they're
just compensated the three houses
they're not down so people got a
motorway at the end of their garden but
its sympathy for Stanley there Esther
you hear your first story and this on
the front page of The Sunday Times I
suppose in the wake of Savile 20 private
schools facing ruinous child sex abuse
pedophiles are vile callous criminals
target vulnerable kids and if there are
kids whose parents are a long way away
and they're quite young a teacher and
authority in the olden days and
maybe today who knows could have his
wicked way with them but there are two
things about this story which really
really annoying me one is um a lawyer
one lawyer representing the kids and now
grown up of course says the new cases
were drawn from the upper echelon of
society which was unusual in child sex
abuse claims what planet's him running
on what he think the only common kids
get sexually abused has he network
heavens so sack that lawyer suck it
sudden she around some calls but for
sacking and then the other thing are
equally stupid and uninformed about
child abuse stairs what is most
unsettling said this writer in the
Sunday Times is that the teacher
involved were all popular with boys and
staff none came close to the caricature
of the teacher abuser as a creepy weirdo
Jimmy yeah we know is that monsters
don't get near children nice men do
obviously the people who want to win the
confidence and trust not just that the
kids they're grooming but the adults
around them will appear to be the most
popular successful happy-go-lucky
teachers but I'm real stereotyping there
isn't a yes no you didn't some of the
Johnsons go to one of the schools
mentioned dummy you just need to find
out it's for out of a potential six went
to UM one of the school so I can just
put in a word for this school of the
mend ashdown house on the front page of
your paper yesterday well i'm going to
put in a word for you did a very good
job as far as concerned i know nothing
about these indications that's what
Manny will said in them forty tires he's
remember I know Nelson barcelo there I
know nothing and I'm going to stick with
saying these are good schools and Joe
has proved otherwise I want to do oh
eight hundred double one double one if
any young person watching this program
is suffering at the hands of teacher or
anyone else child I'll is there for you
chard line will listen and it's
confidential and safe it's open day and
night oh eight hundred double one double
one okay let's say go to a very much
lighter story Lord Blair they
the mail I love this a 90-pound hair do
is find a but only if you're a ladies as
a lovely piece but yeah exactly two
pieces and it is nice like my mail on
Sunday about mr. Cameron's headers the
first one is brilliantly called Crump a
great crimper gate and but this this
particular piece actually also indicates
who what other people are spending so
we've got Nick Clegg 20 pounds Andrew
Lansley at 15 pounds I hear Richard Dan
it only pays five pounds I don't know
but the great love is by you how much do
you spend i spent about 13 i think it
says you tell i'm on 20 quid I'm afraid
yeah you know it does not work forgive
me yeah I should I go to ozy the barber
you don't care anywhere I'll see the
Barbarian camdenton but do you have a
genetic hair the eccentricities miss you
and your son there's still a great quote
in here it says that men are now getting
the same treatment women have endured
for years oh look at him with his balls
he's spending 90 pounds and he still
looks like a potato all right so let's
say let's move on it over to Stanley
yeah caution your mobile phone is
watching you I mean people kind of knew
this already than they do this is the
baby train anyway because amy davis troy
David it's a remarkable man up tomorrow
a fighter for civil liberties and
pointed out in a long a charter in there
in the mail on Sunday that the
government through its use of what's
called metadata Joey one knows every
time you bring someone up and they who
you ring up they know where you run up
from they can track you you call that
you call s a ransom it's known you call
childline I'll be calling that new line
you've just had our beso called silver
line you know well I say to myself David
Davis is on the right on the right track
here we cannot allow government to know
too much about what we're doing I think
he's absolutely on the wrong track this
is a life-saving matter if two children
have gone missing yeah if they've gone
missing with their mobile phone and you
would respect the right now that's one
thing that's being done is finally learn
to scale
if they're looking you don't even when
they're wrong they can be off it's luck
that's how am I worried someone would
someone might know I'm innocent all but
little baby because he knows about the
policing I suspect governors is if you
have a murder in a field in Berkshire
the first question you ask is what
phones have been in that field do you
remember the little girls in so hardly
they tracked where they've been and
that's how they found in and a missing
child who's gonna hang herself runs
childline so she's gonna hang yourself
she disappeared ok I'm sure your phone
I'm sure you don't disagree with that I
don't but what you want is the checks
and balances do not agree I do agree
really in order to solve one or two
problems like that my own single
important problems of course our missing
child is a tragedy you introduce a
system which weighs so heavily on
society as a whole I think that is the
question see what I'm side what happens
it police lose that right eye damaging I
think it would put policing back 30
years back it would put on integrating
the Glasgow people who blew up the
Glasgow when they drove into the airport
and the police were a few minutes behind
them only all the way from London
because they had the phones they're also
talking about emails the metadata means
they know exactly what email you sent to
doesn't there any other contents but
they know they can apply they in the new
system we they'll be able to apply to
actually say who email to what are you
feeling guilty about family I'm
everything you what did you do well that
is the old clothes I mean that's a way
of saying if you've got nothing to hide
why lucky yeah that's it that's it
that's an easy way out know what you've
been in our they're interesting we
cannot allow government to know too much
about what we're doing okay listen
Esther you bring us back I suppose in a
way to the issue of immigration
migration foreign nurses give NHS a
lesson in tender loving care well I'm
sorry to say this but my experience has
been just that when my late husband was
in hospital with his his final illness
the nurse who was wonderful was an
Australian agency nurse and the other
person in hospital was the spanish
cleaner who made his cups of tea when we
sat by
bedside while I'm afraid too many of the
other nurses were gathering together at
the nurse's station chatting to each
other now you can't actually examine
people you can't put an official
qualification on a bit of paper for care
and compassion but some however as
people are saying these days the nurses
we used to describe as angels are now
highly qualified but not necessarily the
people we would want to know do you
think this is about national
characteristics oh it's just about
numbers isn't it I mean you know I mean
I mean I think you didn't think some
foreign nations are intrinsically more
caring I think that they understand what
the whole nursing role is if I had a
whole group of trainee nurses in front
of me I would say right you're getting
into those hospital beds and you're
gonna feel bloody awful and we're going
to show you what it feels like when
summer do you know I had a friend of
mine who lost his sight he was in
hospital age 90 with a heart attack I'll
asked how the food was he hadn't eaten
any because nobody had noticed he was
blind and therefore couldn't cut up his
own food yes it takes time but it also
takes that bit of empathy and compassion
it's partially to do with make it into a
graduate professional it's the same as I
was objected to the police be an
entirely graduate profession it's not
right you know do it that way you need
your lessons in life and I think what
we're missing here okay I very last a
quick last aureus naughty Johnson
William to lead global battle against
poachers is this what he's learning at
Cambridge I think you probably is
wearing something about that but they
have taken the lead the royal family
ever since pretty Consuela paducah been
bruh and Prince Charles this is a vital
issue now the elephants are going down
the drain the Tigers getting done train
the riders are going down the drain
something needs to be done what needs to
be done is to get the Chinese above all
the cut back on there tomorrow that's
why William Hague pity you didn't ask
William Hague about writers and Titus
the other the other moment of it if I
may call you dumb it in you you may i'm
calling you Stanley but I wrote us or
some other day I read a book or where
the wild things were and that tries to
pin down these issues and this
conference at Lancaster House next month
may be a start must end it there thank
you
much indeed Stanley Johnson Esther
Rantzen Orion black very good to see you
all that thank you once again